I cross $100 million in net worth at age
31 I'm 35 significantly higher than that
now and I have the privilege of talking
to lots of people who are at Billion
Dollar Plus and so in this video I want
to break down a handful of themes that
I've seen repeated that can make you
significantly more successful the rich
by time the poor bu stuff ambitious
people bu skills and lazy people by
distractions as much as these seem like
four different groups it's really like
you have these pairings rich people use
money to buy time ambitious people use
time to buy skills and the reason it's
ambitious people is because generational
wealth isn't transferred through assets
it's not transferred through stuff it's
transferred through education it's
transferred through skills and so
there's this Sanskrit proverb that I
love if you have a good son you don't
need to accumulate wealth if you have a
bad son there's no point in accumulating
wealth and so the idea that you're going
to pass on your wealth to a child who
doesn't have the skills makes it
irrelevant because fundamentally either
it is a good son who has skills and then
if the son has skills then whether you
transfer the wealth or not makes the
wealth itself irrelevant and I find that
there's so many things that are like
this in wealth creation that you don't
understand until you're on the other
side of it because the answers that
you're looking for are not in your
newsfeed they are not in the distraction
and so the vast majority of lazy people
that I have encountered continue to
distract themselves because the
difficulty of looking at themselves in
the mirror and saying I am inadequate is
too painful and so instead they would
rather watch fluff videos on the
internet that make them feel good and
tickle their ears rather than confront
reality that they are just not good
enough and so they consume the stuff
that's like I am worthy I deserve these
things in other words entitled to them
which by the way if you feel entitled to
something then when you get it you are
never grateful because you thought you
deserved it to begin with we know that
gratitude for example is something that
increases your subjective well-being in
life which is that you enjoy life more
when you for what you get which means
that you have to by very definition
expect nothing which means you're
entitled to nothing which means that you
deserve nothing in reality you are
worthy only of the things that you
currently have because you have already
gotten them you have proven that you can
work a minimum wage job so you are
worthy of the compensation of minimum
wage and as much as this is painful and
I'm sure this will get clipped a 100
times to show me as some evil rich guy
or I'm willing to take that hate for the
few people who will hear this message
and decide to change the way they act
you can be ambiti ious and distracted
which keeps you poor when I started out
at my Peak I had nine businesses because
I heard seven income streams make you
wealthy but it doesn't seven income
streams just spread you seven ways and I
had nine I was like well seven good nine
must be better to give you context I had
a chiropractor agency I had a dental
agency I had a gym turnaround business
and then I had at the time six locations
so there's nine whever it is boom and I
had Partners in each of these businesses
I was still the one who was required to
rain make meaning I was the one who was
required to sell customers into all nine
if you are required to work inside of
the business then you can only really do
one job and so when people hear that
someone has seven income streams it's
because they own assets that generate
that kind of income but in order to gain
the cash to then buy the assets that
create the cash flow it requires time
and focus let me make Focus real for you
focus is a very amorphous term focus is
measured by the amount of things you say
no to and inversely you could measure it
by how few things you say yes to meaning
the most focused person says only yes to
one thing and says no to literally
everything else and so the next thing
that separates the rich from the poor is
it's 100x not 2X and so this concept is
one that I had dinner with a friend of
mine who's a public CEO and I asked him
what he had done to grow the business I
think from a $200 million market cap to
a 1.2 billion dollar market cap in less
than two years all right so that's
absurd growth for a company I was like
so you know what what are you doing
primarily and he said I'm shaking hands
I'm kissing babies I'm going to events
all the time and I was like well how
many he's like well I'm going to do 66
events this quarter and I was like in
person he was like yeah I was like they
coming to you and he's like no I'm going
to them I want to make this real he has
a wife he has kids and before anyone
listens and says I can't believe he well
cool he makes trades if anything I would
hope that people watch this and say I
wouldn't make that trade in which case
great also don't complain about not
having with somebody who has made that
trade made and so one of the big
misconceptions by the way this is a
sales thing too is that people want your
outcome their way they want to have
their cake and eat it too they want to
say hey I want to not change the way I'm
eating I want to not change the way I'm
living but I want to have a six-pack and
I want to be in shape I want to continue
to live this way and I want to get the
10 chick or the 10 guy I want to
continue with my work life schedule as I
currently have but I want to have hyper
growth they are trades they're price
tags when you go to the store you either
want the shoes and you're willing to pay
the price or you're not willing to pay
the price that's it you can't pick the
price for the shoes you pay it or you
don't my telephone back to myself is
that I thought I worked a lot when I was
younger and I did spend a lot of time
working but I made so little progress
because a lot of that time I wasn't
actually creating output I encourage
people to do something called the 12 x30
all right so it's it's very simple and
it's actually not as unsustainable as
people would think you work 12 hours a
day for 30 days straight no weekends by
the last day you realize one you aren't
made of glass two how much more you
could be working three how much faster
you could be achieving your goals four
how much you could be getting better
every single day five you don't need to
work like this forever but if you need
to do it for a season or for a reason
sometime in the future you've got that
gear in you and six there are people who
are working more than you who are
beating you and you get all of those
lessons for the low price of getting
more done in a month than you probably
did last quarter it's and so everyone
and like of course you've got one you
know one side of people are like I work
more than this now and of course they
don't they obviously don't and the thing
is is that people are like why I work
like that but I take a couple days off
right that's the point is that you have
to push through it now can you work 16
by 30 sure if you want to you're welcome
to work more than that CU I've found
that working six to six is kind of like
what I do every day anyways I'm on 12 by
100 you know in terms of how I think
about working there's plenty of days
that I work 15 16 hour days cuz I get
here at 5 or 6 and then sometimes we
have an event we have dinner things like
that afterwards and ends at 9:00 and
that's where you have to be on not just
at the office not just in front of your
computer but people actually demanding
things of you on a regular basis all the
time being on camera and I'll tell you
that there are levels to this like
working alone for a full day is not as
exhausting as being on stage for a full
day being on camera for a full day
because every second that you were not
Peak you were losing you can take a
break while you're working alone you
can't take a break when you're on stage
when you're meeting customers when
you're making content like right like
like every minute that is not recorded
is basically a minute wasted there's a
whole team here behind this camera right
that is making this stuff for you and
I'm costing them every second I'm not
showing up I remember there was a period
of season of my life where I think I had
like nine straight uh months of this and
it was not 12 it was 15 16 because I had
to wake up at 4: to get to the gym where
I was at the gym but I wake up at 4: and
then I would get the the class ready I'd
open the gym doors at 4:30 which start
the classes at 5:00 and the last class
at night would end it would be a 7:00
class it would end at 8: and then at 8:
I would then do billing I'd reach out to
old customers I would confirm lead
appointments for the next day all that
sometimes until 10: 11: at night and
then I'd wake up again at 4 and so I
don't know what the hours are there but
it's more than 12 and I did that for 9
months straight and I used to describe
it as the kind of tired a good night's
sleep couldn't fix it was like it was
tired it was deeper than like a one
sleep I needed like weeks to like
basically come back to normal and the
thing is is that I think it is valuable
because you have to learn that you have
that gear I think that that gives you
Supreme confidence when you're entering
any new Endeavor because you know that
you have acquired the trade of being
relentless that you do not relent you do
not let up you do not stop until you get
what you want and you know that you can
push through being tired or being
underslept or being overwhelmed because
you realize that you didn't die and that
you've done this before and so the
difference between the Newbie and the
veteran is that the veteran looks on
something and looks back on what they
have done to get to that point and says
I've seen this before this is another
one of those and that's why they don't
have the anxiety that's why don't have
the stress that's when they get on stage
they crush it that's when they the high
pressure situation they still breathe
normally their heartbeat doesn't go up
because they've done it before and the
only way that you can get to the point
where you can say you've done it before
is to do it now and so I Define work as
volume times leverage and so it's about
how many times you do something and how
much you get for each time you do it in
the beginning you need to do a lot more
of this right you do way more volume
because of that volume you gain skill
and then the leverage also increases and
so you get 100x the volume which then
over time builds skill which then gives
you more for what you put in and then
over time that continues to increase
your output the thing is that this
concept of 100x not 2x has applied to so
many different areas of my life like
when I paid a large brand for insight
into how I could grow my personal brand
when I decided to get into this game I
was like hey I'm not growing that fast
uh and he said oh well pull up your
social media profiles and we pulled him
up one by one and he said look what
you're doing look what I'm doing and he
had genuinely been doing 10 times more
volume than I was doing and so he
basically said you're not doing enough
volume I then said okay that was clear
as day I need to do more volume and the
thing is is when we did more volume we
got better at doing it and so now we
continue to do the same volume as I did
in the beginning which is 10 times more
than when I started we get even more
output and then I had a different friend
who talk to me billionaire guy he was
thinking about getting into content and
he said hey I'm really not growing that
fast and I got to have the exact same
conversation with him but the thing is
is that this guy had done 100x not 2x
before in his life it was just that he
got to realize like me that it has been
100% domain specific and so when he then
I showed him my Instagram and his I
showed him my Tik Tok and his I showed
him my YouTube and his and I said dude
I'm making 450 pieces a week you're
making seven and he was like got it like
understood he immediately got it because
he had already learned that lesson in a
different domain I want to I want to
zoom out for a second right now is a
period of time where I'm working really
hard I'm working a lot I'll give you
context as what a lot is for me so this
year the first hundred days of the year
I didn't have a day off and so my time
was only spent working and so it's like
well what's the difference between when
you were quote working all the time when
you're younger and working all the time
now is that what I get done in a day is
significantly greater than what I got
done and the quality of that work is
also higher because the thing is is that
you learn how to work you get better at
working the more you do it and so a lot
of people are like man I I feel like I'm
not that productive when I work like
what should I do it's like work more
like you work more until you get better
at working I remember when I was a legal
intern at a at a company in France
called ARA ARA if you want to how they
say it and I was a legal intern
and I was spending the whole summer
there which by the way they always
trying and like use and abuse interns I
was like man I'm I'm working so hard and
I talked to one of these legal partners
and I only had one exchange with this
particular legal partner who's you know
high up in the firm and she said oh she
was like that's cute you don't even know
what work is she said you don't even
know how to work just like you spend
time here just like but you don't know
how to work I just remember how
dismissive uh what she said was but I I
understood I mean I understand now
especially what she meant was like
you're spending a lot of time here but
you're not getting anything done and it
takes time it takes reps to get better
at working itself and so that measure of
focus the equal opposite of distraction
is just how long you can stick with it
and I can tell you that me from a very
visual perspective when I work there are
many times like you know when you work
and you're like man I feel like I I like
need a break the thing is is that that
break period for people who aren't as
good at working might be like the rest
of the day and the better and better
that I've gotten at working is that I
can like kind of like whip my like whip
my head back in and be like confront
like keep going and I'm like all right
I'm going to keep going and then you
kind of realize that there's like a 5
minute sometimes 15 minute period where
like your output slows a little bit but
then you catch the next draft and then
you're in again it's being able to whip
yourself back in and that muscle of
doing that takes practice and the only
opportunity that you get to flex that
muscle to practice it is to work
yourself to the point of fatigue to the
point or distraction or respite or rest
would be beneficial or you feel like
it's what you crave right now and then
being able to be like no I can power
through this and the thing is is you can
you can power through it it just takes
practice and practice takes repetition
and being willing to be uncomfortable
for an extended period of time and it's
kind of like when you're eating and
you're dieting there are moments where
you get these Cravings where you're like
man I'm starving I want something sweet
if you've ever dieted before and this is
where repetitions help it only lasts
like 20 minutes so if you ever do this
by the way dieting hack is just set a
timer when you're like man I really want
something wait 20 and if you still want
it which you rarely do because it
usually lasts less than 20 sometimes
it's just five it'll just go away and
the same thing happen happens with Focus
but we then just take off we take off
for our diet for the day we order a
pizza right we order ice cream right or
we take off working for the day right
and we just say I'm just going to watch
Netflix for the rest of the time or I'm
just going to go hang out with friends
whatever or I'm going to go out but I
will say now that I have worked for a
100 days straight and that was in the
earlier part of this year I think this
year I've probably taken three or four
days off since the year started and I
still probably worked until like two on
those days but I still consider consider
those like more or less days off you're
not going to die and so I think back
retroactively or like historically like
there were people who were forced to
work for years on end or they would get
killed as gruesome as that may seem I
see that as hopeful in that they have
already demonstrated that it's possible
like you can work continuously for an
extended period of time because
fundamentally you're just alive you're
moving right and like you think Super
ancestors it's like they didn't have
computers they like they just were
around and so you do keep busy while
you're awake and so you might as well
keep busy continuing to nudge things
forward and I can't tell you the amount
of times where now I'm like my mind
checked out and I was like no I my brain
checked out a little bit but I'm going
to I'm just going to keep I'm going to
keep going and then 3 hours 4 hours 6
hours more past and I'm like oh I
actually finished everything that I said
I was going to do and it's just so much
more work and it's fewer days off and
it's earlier mornings and longer nights
and it it it just it's being able to do
that for an extended period of time I
know the whole idea of like you know
work on the things you love and you'll
never work other day in your life that's
just I just don't think it's true like
there's the so many things that I don't
enjoy doing that I have to do and that's
why at least for me my saying is always
um I will do what is required how I feel
about it is relatively irrelevant
because the things that have come from
doing what is required have made doing
the requirements something that I know
will pay off and so I kind of like Feast
on those morsel of past achievements as
the fuel to continue doing things that
may be uncomfortable or unpleasant in
the moment and most work isn't
unpleasant it's just work it's like I
have to get this done right and you like
I get to get this done sure but like I'm
just being real for me it's it's usually
not sunshine and rainbows like I I work
a lot and I I get and I'm tired you know
I I um I slept nine hours last night
which was the first time I've slept 9
hours in a while and I feel amazing
right now but sometimes you got to work
on six sometimes you got to work on five
and so think about this hypothetical
extreme let's say that you played video
games that was all you did when I say
that's all you did you didn't go out you
didn't talk to people you didn't see
anyone you didn't eat you didn't sleep
but you would be incredibly focused now
at that point you say well in order for
him to play more video games he needs to
sleep so there are contingencies right
you do need to eat or you'll die and so
there are the fewest requirements
necessary to maintain consistent focus
on the one thing and those thing become
requisites for Focus rather than
distraction like there are periods of
time where you will need to rest that
rest therefore is productive because it
increases your total output in the one
thing that gets you the most leverage
that gets you closest to your goals in
the shortest period of time and so this
isn't a video of me saying you know work
until you die well you will work until
you die because we all will die and we
all probably will work at some point but
it is more video of saying that every
single thing that is not a requisite for
you continuing to do the one thing that
one yes are all distractions they are
all things that take away and people
have a hard time with this because they
like to say like you need to have
balance but this is what poor people do
not understand and I am going to do my
very best to kind of like pass down a
message from the future to my past self
about this and this goes for
entrepreneurs specifically which is you
do not understand how much work it is
like you think you understand how much
work it is and I've had multiple times
in my life where I've met someone who
was way further ahead than me and I saw
them actually working five to 10 times
more than me and I was like Wow and
there's the scene in Invictus which is a
movie with Morgan Freeman and Matt Damon
I love this moment there's an exchange
I'm paraphrasing but he says something
to the extent of I've heard that you've
been playing with an injury and Matt
Damon just kind of says well no one ever
plays it 100% And I just love that
because to me that kind of encompasses
the champion mindset which is that it's
not about playing when circumstances are
perfect it's that playing creates
perfect circumstances we have to learn
to play When the chips are stacked
against us it's like having values
values are only valuable when they are
test it you can say you're loyal but if
you know a girl if you're in a hotel
room and a girl is there and your wife
isn't there and there's no way that she
finds out that is the test of whether
you're loyal it's when there's Stakes
test of whether you have work ethic is
whether you can work when you're tired
it's whether you can work when you're
distracted it's whether you can work on
things that you don't find Pleasant
because all of the and I see this with
you know some of the young guys like
there was a guy we hired and then in 3
days he said I don't think this is for
me and he got hired to a sales Ro he was
he was making outbound calls I was like
you don't think this is for you I was
like you don't even know what's for you
you were here for 3 days you didn't even
get the ability to get good at the basic
thing and so there's a level of
intolerance for discomfort in some sort
of expectation that it's going to be
this amazing thing that you're going to
love at all times and it's just not and
so I would I'm okay being a different
voice in the in The Entrepreneur Space
that's not like you know passion is what
is what gets you through the the hard
times I don't think so passion has not
been the thing that has gotten me
through my my harder times it has been
desire it has been wanting to make
something into a reality by dragging
something from your mind into the world
and sometimes I feel like you're giving
birth to this thing which for every
mother which I obviously haven't given
birth it's like you give birth Kicking
and Screaming it's a painful experience
but then there's life that happens
afterwards and I see work as very much
labor and we even use the same word it's
labor it's work it's it's painful the
pain is that like you're halfway through
I would imagine and you're like I still
have to keep pushing cuz it's still not
alive yet it's still not out and so I
think learning to push through that and
this is the part that my friend was
saying where he's like they don't get it
they don't get it they think that I do
one of these speaking events and they
see my Instagram and they think oh okay
well why is my brain not growing like
that he's like well I was in five
different cities this week and I just
had to do FaceTime with my kids in order
for them to see me and people are then
like I wouldn't make that trade fine but
don't want what he has and so let me let
me draw this out for you in a nice
little visual to show you how I see work
right this volume that you need to do so
you have excitement right so when you
have this new idea which we have them
and you're like oh my God this is
amazing right this is so good the thing
is is that once you become neutral and
then you become worried and stressed
this is when work begins and so in the
bodybuilding world they'd be like okay
once you have achieved failure that is
where your working reps begin it's an
old school bodybuilding sake I'm sure
the science Bros will be upset about it
but I think that it very much qualifies
for how it relates to work in this world
is is is that your motivation Fades very
quickly it's that work begins once
motivation stops and I think if you
measure it that way then you will
measure how much you work and how hard
you work very differently so it reminds
me of this Muhammad Ali quote where he
says I hated every minute of training
but I would tell myself suffer now and
live the rest of your life as a champion
I have this uh tweet that I said a
minute ago that I really like and so
whenever I get to a low point where I
think why do I even bother I just try
and remind myself this is where most
people stop and this is why they don't
win that period that wall that you hit
like that is that is the champion wall
that is where you you leave everyone
else behind because everyone only works
until their point of excitement and then
they stop it's like you have to find
that next gear so the next point is that
they cannot
copy your proof people want to gain
reputations they want to be known for
for certain things they want to get
status but people can copy your promises
they can copy your services they can
copy your logo they can copy your name
but they can't copy what you've done I
have sometimes younger entrepreneurs who
reach out and they're like hey I want to
build a big brand and um they're like I
want to start making content but I
advise them to only make content if
they're truly documenting and don't
transition into teacher mode because the
thing that will build your brand is the
stuff you do like we look at the
business Titans that are out there you
look at El you look at Bezos you look at
maybe now Sam Alman you look at Jensen
hang from Nvidia and they now have these
quote big business Brands Steve Jobs
Bill Gates Warren Buffett they are
considered probably the leaders of the
business World in terms of thought
leadership but did they get there by
building personal brands or did they get
there by building personal businesses
and then by building personal businesses
which I'm joking here they just built
big ass businesses by extension people
wanted to know who was the person behind
this big business business and then they
built their credibility before they
built their likeability everyone wants
to put the car before the horse everyone
wants to put the uh they want to eat the
pudding before they have the proof yeah
the proof comes before the pudding in
the real world in a world where anyone
can say anything and get instant reach
trust is the thing that is the scarcity
that is the that is the rare commodity
and so the idea is if you want to build
a really big brand then you want to
index super hard on trust and the way
that people can trust you is that you do
what you said you have done the reason
Mr Beast videos work worked is because
he used his videos as proof he didn't
say I am super knowledgeable he said
look I did something that no one else is
willing to do his first video that went
viral was him counting to a million or
something crazy right and so he did
something that other people were not
willing to do and so he just happened to
have documented that thing and so if
you're like well how do I get proof I'm
So Young it's like well you just do epic
stuff and then people will be like wow
he did epic stuff this is interesting
and so it still requires epic amounts of
work in order to do that the reason that
there's such a misconception about
overnight success is that it's just that
there's a threshold over which you are
good enough that you go viral all right
and so this is call it like here is the
viral you know viral moment all right so
this is our viral moment right here the
thing is that we the person lived this
whole life what we in the public see is
this moment what happened since and so
we have the perception of overnight
success and this is why it's so
difficult for people to wrap their heads
around because they want to model what
they see not what occurred and so we
have to model what they did not what
happened and so this fundamentally is
the inputs this is what they put in for
a long period of time what we see here
is the output this is what's visible and
so this is where it gets especially
difficult for people trying to learn is
that most people get rich and then they
get weird and then what happens is
people then try and copy what they do
here not what they did to get there and
so they copy the wrong stuff they model
the plateau not the rise so you don't
get rich by flying on private jets you
get rich then you can fly on private
jets and so so a big thing that richer
people do is that they will act with
urgency and I would say that this is
just not even richer people this is
entrepreneurs specifically that I'm
making this video for is that they act
with urgency all right and so you can
tell in some ways how how successful
someone's going to be by how quickly
they do things the gap between thoughts
and action and so this is something I
personally work on a lot which is like
how quickly between when I make a
decision to do something does it
actually occur and you can improve your
potency as a person how powerful You Are
by decreasing the gap between thoughts
and action like if you think about the
hypothetical extreme of this the god
figure if you will thoughts and reality
are one and the same he thinks planets
and universes and they appear and so
that would be the ultimate demonstration
of power in my opinion and so we can
approximate that we can get as close to
that as we can by shrinking the time it
takes between when we think and when we
decide and then when we ultimately do
when you don't have any more information
to collect in order to make a decision
then you make the decision and you make
the decision by eliminating Alternatives
so like literally the word decide comes
from decader which is Latin for to cut
off and so the question is what thing
are you eliminating by making the
decision that you're going to make and a
really easy tactical thing is is
whenever you say I'm going to get this
done by the end of the week ask yourself
can I get it done by the end of to day
and that seems like a very small hack
but that increases your pace of progress
by 7x and so if you hear that you're
like wow 7x it's like yeah and for that
reason there are people who are working
100 times faster than you and I think
that this is a really good cultural
thing which is uh you can just say end
of day
not end of week and not end of month end
of week so in each of the instances this
is a 4X increase this is a 7x increase
right and you can even go end of day
goes into end of hour now this is one
that Lila talks about a lot and she's a
master operator is that she heard this
from a mentor she said if it's a five
minute task and you have 5 minutes do it
now and so the amount of times where I'm
like hey we should do this thing and
then literally in 60 seconds it's
handled by Lila like while I'm just
walking around talking just like
shooting ideas out there is baffling and
so her speed of like that's a great idea
it's already been you know delegated out
like she doesn't keep things on her
plate and so there's this big falseness
that I think is propagated by a lot of
the social media world because it feels
good and to get lots of shares because
it gives people permission to be lazy it
gives people permission to tell
themselves that they're great just the
way they are I wholeheartedly reject
that entire notion the idea that they
sell you is that you're young you've got
time and I think that is false because
all this does is extend how long it
takes you to remember that number one
tomorrow isn't guaranteed like I just
looked at my newsfeed this morning and I
there was a guy that I knew who's my age
and he just died of stomach cancer
really sad really nice guy wife and
three kids into fitness really in shape
just a freak thing that happened and so
the assumption that you've got time
assumes that you know you're going to
live forever that you know you're going
to live to 100 and we know that that's
not true and let me put this in
perspective three out of 10,000 people
live to 100 and so everyone has this
assumption in their mind that they're
like yeah I'm at 50 so I'm going to make
it to 100 yeah well you've got a three
in 10,000 shot of doing that very
unlikely more realistically you'll die
at the median which is 74 for men in the
US which means that at 37 you're
actually at the halfway point just in
years but if you adjust for the increase
in speed of time so the same reason that
your kid at five years old thinks that
something takes forever when you say
it's going to happen next year and when
you're 40 something that happens next
year feels like you blink your eyes and
it's there is that when you're five one
year is 20% of your life when you're 40
one year is 2 and a half% of your life
and so it very much in a realway is 9
times faster than it is for your
5-year-old and so it's my belief that as
we get older we don't become more
patient time just moves faster and so if
you adjust for that time speed your
midpoint isn't 37 it's closer to 21 and
so this is also why in my opinion when
you think back on your life you have so
much meat in the first 20 years so much
stuff happens all these material life
events and it's because in that time
period it was half of your life and then
after that everything happens real fast
and so what you have to realize is one
tomorrow isn't guaranteed two nothing is
going to be easy just get over it every
time you think oh this could look just
get immediately skip to oh that's not
true there's something I don't know
about that just skip to it the faster
you can train that muscle that as soon
as you have this fomo just slow down and
realize that you don't know enough three
it takes time to get good there's no one
who's good at anything that was
immediately good at it and the people
who were immediately good at it I
remember telling a professor I was like
you know I've just naturally been good
at languages he was like when you were a
kid did you have multiple languages in
your household and I was like well yeah
I bilingual and he's like what are you
even talking about like you literally
started with that so of course languages
are easier for you and so the thing is
is that the people who have things that
come naturally to them they just only
came because they forgot the work that
generalized to the new skill once you
realize that it takes time repetitions
that get good then you also realize that
the sooner you start the sooner you get
and don't stop until you do so let's
assume you act with urgency right you've
gotten that done you've moved end of
week to end of day you've moved end of
day to end of this hour you've moved end
of month to end of this week and you've
massively increase the speed that you
execute well then you start running Face
Forward into the fact that things are
going to get really hard really fast and
so I will I will tell you this one is
that hard is for now not forever and so
the good thing about bad times is that
they end and the bad thing about Good
Times is that they also end and so
whenever you're going through a good
season it's also a good reminder that
this too shall pass and so what ends up
happening is that when you're in the
hard time that can give you that
necessary spite it can give you the end
of the the tunnel that you can look
forward to there's only three outcomes
you either quit it gets easier or you
get harder so think about that because
no matter what it always ends but you
only lose when you quit before you see
it through because two out of the three
outcomes get easier either it relents
the outside circumstance gets easier
like the hard thing moves or you become
harder and then by extension it no
longer feels hard for you which I'll
make this real for you right now think
about the problems that you were
stressed about 5 years ago in your
business right think about the things
that you were dealing with what you were
stressed about now think about you
trying to solve those problems today
it's probably a joke to you now you'll
be like well yeah obviously it's not
that those things became less hard you
became better but here's where this gets
really interesting for me it just means
that nothing is inherently hard to begin
with anyways we are just always
inadequate for me I remember when I had
five employees and I was like man it's
so many people to manage or you know I
was like where am I G to you know I have
to manage cash flow how do I do that or
like how am I going to get new customers
like how do I how do I S I can't sell
really expensive stuff like what if
someone gets obset you know if I if I
charge more right what if what if
someone finds out I charged this much as
though it's like something wrong like
all of these things are just just
irrelevant to me now just so silly
though for me at the time they were
difficult and I Can Only Imagine how
inconsequential the problems that I deal
with growing hopefully $3 billion doll
companies right now within the portfolio
compared to what Elon deals with having
six multiple hundred billion dollar
companies and I I compare myself to that
so I can always feel like I have a long
way to go but let me give you one thing
that that'll also give you a little bit
of Hope about these these hard times is
that these hard times are
also your best times
but only in reverse and so let me
explain what I mean by that think about
the times when you were younger and you
were in love and you were poor and
you're like man those were the good old
days the thing is is that when you were
in that moment it was stressful you
didn't know how you're going to make
ends meet how you're going to make rent
where you're going to get food whatever
it is you have these these hard times
the hard times that you go through today
but these Hard Times become the good old
days and so we only see the truth when
we look back you have to go through them
to get the perspective and it's
something that I try and like remember
on a regular basis that like I'm going
through the good old days and if they're
the good old days in the future they
might as well be the good old days today
so let me tell you a little bit about
what it feels like throughout this
entire process because if you were
consistently growing you were
consistently in pain that's why they're
called Growing Pains not growing Joys
and if you have stress from growth
remember the alternative is that you can
have stress from stagnation and you can
have stress from decline which
fundamentally means that hardness and
stress is a fact of life you will always
have stress you will always have
problems and the largest problem of all
the largest stressor of all is
determining that having problems is a
problem is that being stressed means
there's something wrong with you but
being stressed just means you're alive
having problems just means that you are
actually doing something I'll tell you
this story that I think can drive this
home and I think this is the path to
fulfillment over
comfort so imagine you talk the creator
of the universe before birth and pick
the person you get to become you say I
want to be the most courageous the
Creator replies and says well then I
will give you monsters to terrify you so
that you can conquer them then you say
well I want to be patient the Creator
replies well then I will make you work
harder and longer so you can learn to
wait so then you say I want to be wise
and the Creator replies then I will give
you failures that will crush your spirit
so you can learn the value of judgment
you then say sounds like a rough life
can you give me a good life greater
replies just like we measure the quality
of a blacksmith by the strength of his
steel I measure you by what you are at
the end not the fire and the hammer it
took to make you a good life isn't a
life that's easy a good life is a life
that makes you into a good person and
that my son is a hard life and so I
remember when I when I sold gym lunch
there was a year that I more or less
took off I had all these kind of
existential crises that I was going
through because all I had been doing is
just working and working working then I
hadn't like put my head up to like look
around and and smell the roses per say
the problem that I had was that when I
was smelling the Roses I was miserable I
was very sad and the the sadness for me
came from the thing that I had that was
most reinforcing my life was the work
that I was doing that was the thing that
was that I enjoyed the most and so not
having that actually created a huge loss
for me and so then I had to create like
what am I doing like why am I here right
and so for me that was when I created
the hypothesis or at least the thesis I
have for my life was that hard work is
the goal is that nothing left in the
tank which I got from Jesse hler which I
love emptying the tank every day is the
point because for me those are the days
that when I look back are the days that
I feel the most fulfilled on in the
moment you feel tired you feel exhausted
you feel like you're bored you feel like
you don't want to do another repetition
you don't want to do another two hours
but another two hours another repetition
another edit is what is required not
what you want but is what is required
and if you have a little bit left in the
tank and you don't know if you have a
little bit left in the tank until you
empty it until you physically can and so
I think about that steel that we're
trying to make and the only difference
is that we are both the steel and the
blacksmith and so the Creator in this
would just give you the fire and either
you can stand far enough away from it
that it just keeps you warm or you can
go into it and you can hammer out the
impurities so that you can just become
better and better and better and
stronger and if you're watching this and
you would like to start a business but
you're not sure where to start I am a
co-owner of school and we just started
the school games and right now we're
giving $100,000 away in cash or a cyber
truck to the person who builds the
biggest community on school in 30 days
and so school is just a community
platform that helps people start
businesses and right now one out of two
people who start a community a paid
community on school make their first
dollar online and so you're like okay
well that's cool and right now on
average the average paid Community owner
makes $1,360 per month so this is not
going to be the thing that makes you you
know a billionaire rich but it can help
you get started which is why I invest in
the company I spent four years looking
for something that could make the
easiest kind of starter business for
people to get going especially starting
online the reason that we have this
success rate right the reason that we
have this very high success rate is that
I meet every single week and on board
new people so every Monday I'm on a call
and I on board uh you know right now I
think it's about 300 people per call
that are on there uh and so I answer
questions live uh with everyone on there
and it's a lot of times it's the same
faces so while the the calls relatively
small I'd encourage you to come on on
top of that I have kind of like
step-by-step instructions of exactly
what you need to do that the best
community owners have done and so you
can just model the behaviors just do
this stuff I don't explain psychology
and triggers and NLP it's just like do
this stuff and this is what yields this
outcome right and then finally we'll
give you the entire platform that
basically makes all the tech really easy
and so right now we've got people who
are in foreign countries who don't speak
English uh we've got I mean I think
there was a guy who won the gam who's 15
years old so like I'm telling you it's
not rocket science like we've really
taken a lot of effort to make it as
simple as humanly possible you don't
need any other software to make this
work and so if that sounds at all
interesting the best part about all of
this is that you can start absolutely
free and so we have the course we have
the calls we have the platform we also
have the community of other people all
right and so you can start for free get
14 days uh you can click the link which
is uh right here oops other way around
school.com games start for free and
hopefully I'll see you on the other side
and so a big part of why this is so hard
is that so few people want to go into
the fire right and the fire could be
entrepreneurship the fire could be
content creation the fire could be
starting a new product the fire could be
doing Outreach and knocking on doors or
quitting your job and and and starting
another job in a completely different
industry that's the fire it's the thing
that other people aren't willing to do
and they tell you not to do it because
helps them justify the risk that they
chose not to take it helps them them
feel better about the risks they aren't
willing to make I remember thinking
about this at long length when I was
younger and I thought about the word
exceptional right so buried in the word
itself is the key point which is that
you cannot expect to be accepted if you
want to be exceptional to become
exceptional by definition you have to
become the exception which means you
have to be unlike other people you have
to do what they don't agree with if they
agreed with you if everyone agrees with
you you can be sure that it's the wrong
path when I quit my job every single
person in my life told me it was a bad
idea I graduated three years from
vanderbelt I had a nice W CER consulting
job I was set up to go to grad school to
one of the Ivy Leagues I aced my gmats
like I was set up I'd done the path and
so for me to quit and be like I'm going
to I'm going to be a personal trainer
for minimum wage at a gym that was not a
happy news for the vast majority of
people that I knew but the thing is is
that I've had those conversations
multiple times in my life when I ended
up leaving the gyms and started the
turnaround business every person was
like you finally made this thing work
you finally you know now we finally
agree with you again and it was right at
the point where they accepted me that I
was like you know what I think I want to
do this other thing and I'm going to
sell all these gyms for basically
nothing in 90 days to then start new and
they're like but you spent so long on
this and they see sunk cost fallacy and
the thing is is don't listen to the
people who are closest to you listen to
the people who are closest to your goals
and so a lot of people like to think
about how they have these mentors and
these Heroes but the most important
group is your reference group and your
reference group is who you compare
yourself to but the thing is that people
think they compare themselves to their
mentors and their Heroes but they don't
who you compare yourself to is who
influences your decisions so the voices
you hear the voices you listen to when
you're about to make a big move those
voices are your actual reference group
and if those voices are not close to
your goal you should not listen to them
if anything Sometimes the best advice in
the world is do the opposite of whatever
it is that they did to get in their life
if you want what they have don't listen
to what they say even when you're an
entrepreneur so let's fast forward a
couple years so there was a point where
I started uh the outbound team so this
is sound super tactical but I'm going to
zoom out for you so we at gym launch had
we were all paid ads for the most part
we I had made content I had a book like
there were things that were out there
but still 70% plus of my of my new
customers came from Paid ads and I knew
that if I wanted to sell the company I
would have to create a second
acquisition channel that was very
different from the primary one so that I
could create more stability so you don't
have one itis one point of failure
within the business and so I remember
reading this book about how to set up
outbound and it said it will take a year
and I said I'm really good at marketing
I'm really good at sales it'll take me
12 weeks and it took 12 months like the
book said and so when I walked through
that what was interesting is it took 90
days for us to get our first sale and
the whole time I'm investing in this
team I'm investing in software I'm
investing in training and Consulting to
like learn how to get all this stuff
going just to get our first sale but
that's not very good for the amount of
time and effort we put into it and then
three months you know after that we
started getting a couple sales trickling
in still not a lot and I actually had
almost like an intervention for my my
executive team that were like hey we
think this is shiny object they're using
my words against me like we think this
is a distraction it's it's not you know
yielding a result for us I don't I think
we should you know cut our losses and
and move on and I just I kept thinking
to myself like this is what hard feels
like like we have to just keep inching
our way through because we have made
sales which me we could just we just
need to get more efficient at it and
then we did another six months and then
we got to the point where it became 50%
of Revenue but here's the thing that you
you don't see and so whether you're
starting a new acquisition Channel like
I was you're starting paid ads whatever
is that if I tell you in one year I
could double your business right let's
say you have to pay me
$100,000 right and in one year I will
double your business many people would
probably be like yeah sign me up I'll do
it maybe I'll take a loan but even for
the 100 like if I know I'm going to
double my business in a year I would do
it okay but then what happens is month
one they drop 5K and then they lose 5K
and then month two they lose 5K again
and then they say ah ads aren't for me
ah outbounds not for me but the thing is
is that the way it actually feels is
that you lose 5K you lose another 5K you
lose another 5K and then all of a sudden
one month you make 25k and then the next
month you make 50k and you make all of
this back and some but it happens all at
once and so there's a saying on Wall
Street that I like which is it happens
slower than you expect and then faster
than you can imagine and they talk up at
that when it comes to Market drops and
Market explosions it's like we should
like this we should be crashing it
hasn't adjusted yet it happens slower
than you expect and then faster than you
can imagine and so you have to be
willing to foro that period of time for
a long time understanding that you just
want to make progress and so I think the
thing that separates masters from
beginners is that Masters have more ways
to win so you can measure your expertise
in anything by the ways you can measure
equaling the number of times and ways
you can win and so if you're an expert
at making videos then throughout the
entire process of a really long project
you have many wins on the way you know
all the little progress markers that
occur to create some big outcome and you
approximate those little progress
markers for the ultimate goal at the end
when you're a beginner you only see the
output and all you see is I'm doing
stuff and nothing is happening but you
just aren't able to mark progress well
and so if you want to increase your
expertise then you need to increase the
number of ways you can measure so that
you can increase the number of wins you
have in a given time period And by the
way that is what makes you enjoy your
work and this is how the work itself
becomes reinforcing and so in order to
develop that expertise you have to have
education and people think that
education is expensive but the only
thing more expensive than education is
not being educated and so I would say
that in my life I spent more money than
I could possibly imagine simply trying
to acquire skills and relationships that
would make me better to give you an idea
I think the most expensive thing that I
bought for this this is not including uh
me messing stuff up and just losing tons
of money but I actually wrote a check
for was $350,000 to have a dinner with a
guy who was worth 7 billion and I got
exactly what I wanted from that dinner
and it was incredibly valuable for me
and uh he kept saying no i i s offered
100K and then 200k 250k and 350k and
when we offered 350k he said fine I'll
just have dinner with you and he didn't
ask for the money but I think he was
just seeing that I was willing to spend
the $350,000 for it and so I've spent so
much money for one hour two hours
anything to gain context because I I
heard this close and you've heard if
you've watched my channel you've heard
this before but pick whatever number
your income goal is right let's say it's
a million doll a year and let's say
you're currently making $100,000 a year
if
you value that million dollar goal the
value of the million dollars per year
what's the price you put on that
education the value of that education is
the difference between where you're at
and where you want to go and so that's
why if I want to if I want to become a
Deca billionaire then I should be
willing to pay everything that I have in
order to gain the skills the experience
the knowledge in order to get there and
so if there's a way that you can spend
$50,000 in order to learn a million
dollar preyear skill set then every year
you don't do it you lose $950,000 that
you would have made if you had made that
investment and so the the key Point here
is that we use poor people language when
we talk about education when we should
be using investor language because it
should be an investment in an asset and
the asset just happens to be you and you
can't sell it but you can invest in it
and you can grow it if you think about
Investments you'll never say an
investment is expensive there's just a
cost and a return but if someone says
there's a $100 stock or a$1 th stock it
could be expensive relative to the
return but if the return is supposed to
be good then no one says that that
amount of money itself is expensive it's
just what the cost is for the return it
is the investment and so if you think
about education in that same way it
always has to be framed in terms of what
you get for it not how much it costs
it's not about how much you make now
it's how much you're going to make and
how much that's worth to you and for me
whatever my Delta is is what I'm willing
to pour into that without hesitation and
so for the first probably I mean shoot I
lost everything at year whatever six of
my entrepreneurial journey and I put all
of the extra money that I had right back
into learning more stuff and so even
though I made profit my like biggest
expense was me but it wasn't on my
living and my lifestyle it was on my
education and my network and my
surroundings and the skills I wanted to
learn the courses the Workshops the
Seminars the coaching programs all the
things that I did I'm a product of that
world despite the fact that I think that
world overall has a lot of shitty people
I still learn a lot and you can learn
just as much by learning what not to do
and say I will never do that or treat
someone the way that person treated me
because the best students never never
come out negative so really like think
that like I have always been the top
performer in every single program
coaching whatever I have ever done and
so the process that I use is number one
do everything they tell you to to the
tea the first time then take what works
and toss the rest you can learn
something from everyone but only take in
that which makes you stronger which is a
quote that I have from Harry Potter the
swort of Gryffindor but I love because
it was enchanted to have this this spell
that it would only take in things that
made it stronger so it took in the bassx
Venom which allowed it to kill you know
the horcruxes later on but I like to see
myself as that sword is that I continue
to invest I continue to put things into
the steel but I only take in that which
makes me stronger so a lot of people
have these negative experiences with
coaches Consultants vendors whatever and
I just like to think to myself like in
what way will this make me better and so
by instead asking that question rather
than enumerating the many things they
could have done better or the things
they did WR WR simply saying there is
something that I can learn from this and
there is something in this experience
that will make me stronger and that
frame may have been one of the most
viable frames that I've had because I
like you have spent plenty of money on
things that have quote not worked but I
still learned enough from them and
oftentimes what not to do that allowed
me to then see what to do but before I
ever did that I had to do the first
three steps of that which was do
everything they said to the tea the
first time and if for whatever reason it
did not work I would then use my other
skills to patch the difference so that I
could find a way to make it work and by
the way if they have a success story
which they usually do because that's how
they sold you is that you find that
person and figure out what they are
doing that is lacking in the education
that the person who's teaching taught
fundamentally if you ever buy something
where there is somebody who has been
successful then it means there are
activities that yield success and the
discrepancy I'm going to show this to
you visually because I think it's
important so let's say there's a bridge
right and you've got you know here's
here's money and here's you okay so
you've got this path that someone uh
shows you how to do so you paid money
and they give you these little bricks
here right they give you these little
bricks that you paid money for and maybe
These Bricks you had to pay different
vendors different amounts of money for
each one of these bricks but you still
haven't made money yet the thing is is
that there's a gap here and the reason
that some people are successful with
some people's in uh you know programs or
implementations and other people aren't
is because that the people who already
bought that brick from somebody else
before that that brick isn't missing and
so if you see the education you have as
these bricks on the road then you
wouldn't say that the foundation of a
house is in some way a ripoff you would
just say it's not a complete house now
if they sold you the expectation that
you would have a house sure you could be
upset by them but they still helped you
build a foundation and so it's the same
people who get upset saying oh I learned
arithmetic from Mrs glass but then when
I found Mr Hardwick and he taught me
calculus she only taught me she's a
you wouldn't say that but for some
reason people talk about the basics of
business the same way when they become
more advanced if someone taught you how
to do outbound and do warm Outreach so
that you could sell your first customers
and someone else later teaches you how
to run ads well you probably learned how
to work the leads from the ads that work
for you because you learned how to do
outbound you probably learned how to
sell because you learned how to sell
strangers and so when you did the ads it
worked for you and then somebody else
who did that same exact implementation
didn't have the bricks that you had and
they never got the dollars that came
across and so whenever something doesn't
work if you can it doesn't make you any
better by saying it's their fault and
fault also only matters in the eyes of
the law which you're not going to sue
anybody anyway so who gives a the
only thing that matters is whether the
outcome happens or not which is under
your control because it means that you
simply have a discrepancy between where
you are and where you want to go and so
a lot of people would then say sure Alex
it's easy for you to say you're a white
guy you're right cool so just don't
watch the video move on um but for
everybody else you've got connections
you've got money you've got looks you've
got intellect or intelligence these are
all great but you can beat all of these
you can beat somebody who has all four
if you have one thing which is the
desire to improve the insatiable desire
to improve no matter where you start if
you have this it's hard to beat someone
who improves every second of every day
without stopping without giving up and
so I have met people who have
connections money looks and intelligence
and they do not people who have an
insatiable desire to improve who do not
stop and so if you think about it like
this if life were a race where at the
end you die so got to finish first right
there are people who may start at
different parts of that race but what is
not measured is the speed that you can
move and so I don't know if you've seen
these these clips that have gone viral
in the NFL where they have like one of
their wide receivers start like 20 yards
behind a fan and they have to race the
length of the football field and then
the wide receiver will usually catch up
like talk to them and then just speed
right past them and so it's far less
about where you start because that's
where a lot of losers will Define
themselves they'll Define themselves by
what happened to them rather than what
they made happen and somebody else may
be here but it only matters if you think
that there's fairness but I don't
believe fairness is something that
exists in the universe and so I don't
hold it as an ideal that I Proclaim must
exist but there is simply a starting
point in a rate of progress and the
starting point you can't control but the
rate of progress you can and so control
what you can control if
education is a change in Behavior that's
what you do if you become educated you
do something different after you learn
something then intelligence is rate of
learning which means that you can in a
very real way influence it's the rate of
learning the speed of learning you can
influence how quickly you move along
this race independent of where you start
and you'll also note that the person
here has no influence on what this
person does these two people are
independent nodes the only reason that
this person gets upset is that they they
think it's not fair and if you just
eliminate fairness from your vocabulary
and think only in terms of what do I
need to do then it eliminates a lot of
the distraction that keeps you poor so
if you call recall from the very
beginning lazy people get distracted
they focus on distraction and one of the
biggest distractions is it's not fair
it's it's not fair I shouldn't have to I
should get I should I should it should
things shouldn't it's all shoulds and I
will tell you that should in my
worldview should not exist because
should creates expectations of an
uncaring Universe it says that you
demand something and I promise you that
the universe will win and so all you
have to do is watch like baby seals just
get immediately eaten by orcas after
like a mother is laying there on the ice
to be like wow life isn't fair I'm sure
that seal could be like it's not fair
that my babies were literally eaten in
front of me tough right tough they have
mammal brains we can see that they got
they got some feelings right and
so if we go back to the Sword of
Gryffindor does demanding that it should
be fair make you stronger does saying
that that person started further ahead
of you in any way benefit you no because
your actions are entirely independent
from them and so the only thing that
that does is actually delay your speed
of taking action it makes you dumber
because if we Define intelligence by
rate of learning then it means it takes
you longer to learn it makes you stupid
and I think that that's why people
people stay here for a very long
time and many of them never leave so
what are the
things that bad entrepreneurs talk about
with good entrepreneurs is one of the
excuses they'll make is that they will
make preference excuses they will make
trade-off excuses they will say this is
not worth the price in which case fine
but don't also want the thing so for
example privacy is the price of Fame
loneliness is the price of ambition
pleasure is the price of discipline
novelty is the price of loyalty
discretion is the price of trust and so
so many people want the benefits of
these traits but can't afford the cost
or the price they're not willing to be
discreet but they want someone to trust
them they can't hold someone Secrets
they they want someone to be be loyal to
them at home but then they want the
thrill of the new relationship they want
the benefits of discipline of
consistency but they can't trade the
pleasure in the moment they want
ambition but they're not willing to pay
the price of being lonely of being the
exception they want fame but then all of
a sudden they are startled when they
realize that they have no privacy and so
each of these things are tradeoffs and
if you're not willing to make the trade
fine but don't about it and and I
think part of it is that we have a hard
time understanding to what degree and so
each of these ideals are not binary it's
not Des discretion it's how much
discretion you have it's not novelty
it's how much novelty it's not pleasure
it's how much pleasure it's not
loneliness it's how lonely and it's not
hard work it's how hard do you have to
work and how long do you have to work
and so most people and I think this is
where a lot of the complaints come is
that they believe they're doing 10 out
of 10 work right they're like I'm do
this is 10 out of 10 hard for me right
now but they're actually only doing one
tenth of the amount of work that it
takes to get to this goal and so might
be doing a 10 out of 10 work for 100k
goal but they're doing a one out of 10
work for a $1 million goal and I think a
lot of that work comes down to being
able to accurately assess reality and
see what your actual discrepancies are
and realize how much work you really
have to do in order to get good at every
one of those discrepancies because most
outcomes don't occur until you've met
all of the conditions like a pipeline
all right so let's say you've got this
pipeline here and you've got these
valves these are the valves you've got
this that's coming here and let's say
once you get all the way through the
water comes out the other side these
valves have to open you have to open
this thing open each of these valves and
let's say you've checked off three of
the four boxes the water's still going
to be stuck here you're still not going
to get the water through and so the
thing is is that as much as you work and
you're like but I did that and I did
that and that didn't work and that
didn't work it may have worked it just
might not have met every condition to
get the outcome and so if you think
about life and outcomes that way it gets
a lot easier because it stops being
emotional you can simply say there's a
condition that I haven't met and I have
to figure out what that condition is
rather than proclaiming that the
Universe isn't fair or that you you
started further back and that's why your
effort hasn't resulted in it maybe and
maybe this person only has to meet three
of these and you have to meet four okay
well then I guess that means that you're
going to be better than them why is that
a bad thing it means that you're going
to develop more skills to achieve the
same goal great if the end of this life
is that you are the steel you are the
thing that gets created then you can't
resent the hammer and the fire that
makes you because you can't wish for
strong character and an easy life
because the price of each is the other
so either people aren't succeeding
because they don't understand that they
have to make a trade that they're not
willing to make or the trade that
they're currently making isn't
sufficient so they either think that
they deserve to get the Nike shoes just
for being who they are and think it's
not fair and think that the store owner
should just give them the Nike shoes and
look all you have to do is look at the
news there's plenty of people who think
that way they go and try and take it
right but that makes them a thief that
makes them significantly worse it
actually does more harm to them in my
opinion but there are people who believe
that that's the worst that's the lowest
level the next level above that is
people who say no I'm willing to pay for
the Nikes but I'll pay 30 it's like yeah
but they're they're 300 that's the price
it's like yeah but I'll pay 30 they
don't extend they don't understand the
extent of the trade-off and then they
complain that their $30 isn't good
enough it shouldn't be so expensive it
is what it is and so there's a saying
that Lea and I say a lot internally I'm
like it takes What It Takes and so if we
want this thing what often has to happen
is you have to keep bidding it's much
more like an auction of a trade-off
because the real world level three is
that you see the Nikes and then you bid
30 and then you realize it's not enough
and rather than moan or put your thing
down and walk away you're like 50
they're like you're like
100 you're like God and so that is the
pain is being able to consistently reset
the expectations and again and again and
again until eventually you make it all
the way through and you bid
$300 you do get your Nikes and then all
of a sudden everyone
says must be nice to be born so
naturally good all you have to do by the
way is watch some of my very first
content pieces and you think my very
first content pieces are the podcasts
that I made various for Content pieces
that I made I made for my gyms 13 years
ago and so it's like man you're so
naturally good on camera watch those
videos tell me if you think the same way
I had to take shots before the videos
cuz I was so nervous about sounding
stupid in the fourth version I would say
like the highest version of this so let
let's I I'll break this down so the zero
level of tradeoffs is should you just
say you should get it for nothing the
next level is too much so you say it's
30 bucks but it's actually 300 and you
say it should the next level is bidding
so you bid so you say say 30 50 100 and
you find out that you're insufficient
and you keep going up the final is
source which is where you determine the
price and this is often in my opinion
where you create your reality so it's
continuing to hammer away at content
continuing to write drafts of the book
before anyone else has seen it because
you are the one that holds a standard
higher than everyone else's because no
longer do you accept the approval of
others as your litmus test the market
for sure in the beginning will tell you
whether you're good or not but Steve
Jobs Henry Ford right they would have
asked for Faster Horses not cars is that
they demand more from themselves than
anyone else does and by setting that
standard here where everyone else is
here by actually meeting the standards
of the market you actually lower your
own and so this is where your standards
become source and this is where you get
into rarified air and this is what the
quote Rich guys if you will when we talk
behind closed doors about what people
don't understand it's about hold the
standard and in my opinion the person
who should make the decision in every
organization is the person who has the
highest standards not the person who's
most senior not the person who has the
most shares it's the person who has the
highest standards for whatever it is our
marketing should be at this level if the
owner thinks it's less then that person
should be the person who's running
marketing if somebody else thinks the
product needs to be this good and
someone else thinks to be less that
person should be in charge whether it's
their first day or the thousandth day
the person who has the highest standards
is the one who should be making the
decision they should become source and
so when you get to that level the only
person you're making trade-offs with is
yourself you're the one who's
determining is this good enough for me
to put my name on rather than is this
good enough for them to say it's good
and for example Jr toen worked on The
Hobbit for a decade and he didn't even
submit the draft one of his friends saw
that he had been working on it for a
decade and submitted it grabbed it from
his desk and submitted it for him to a
publisher and then it obviously became
The Hobbit and and everything came after
that and so his standards were so high
that he still didn't even think it was
ready but it was still so good that they
ended up releasing it now many of you
think that you are Jr Tolkien but most
of you were not it's actually just very
bad and so once you realize how high
your standards really have to be in
order to be excellent will you then have
this daunting realization is that you
can only do shot to four
things in your whole life because of how
long it really takes to get to there and
so it's like I want to be best author in
the the world that's not a desire of
mine to be clear but if I wanted to be
the best author in the world that I know
that that's going to take at least a
decade of actually working hard every
single day to get better and believing
that for me because I'm special I should
somehow be able to be my first book is
an overnight success and and and and
that is the thing that chains you to
mediocrity it's believing that it should
be a different way rather than accepting
reality as it is and then changing your
actions as a consequence and so this is
also why lazy people distract themselves
because
distraction makes you believe the lie
that you can try a hundred things and
then figure out which one works well in
the reality any of them can work but
none of them will work unless you pick
one to work on and then that is you
making it work the vast majority of
things with enough iteration can become
success it's just that people
underestimate how many iterations they
need to have it's 19 drafts not two it's
500 minutes of editing to to make the
video not 50 it's making a th000 phone
calls every week for two years not two
months and so most of the times it's
just that our level of understanding
it's it's here and this is where a lot
of people get stuck a lot of people get
stuck here they say I should be better
this should be easier I've already paid
a little bit I said I was willing to pay
30 the Nike store owner won't give me
the shoes and then you you basically are
the same as this person you just have a
price attach to I should I should it
should be I deserve I am
worth takes what it takes it costs what
it costs you got to be willing to make
the trade and if you're not willing to
make the trade fine just don't complain
and so if you want to become that
exception you want to make those
trade-offs you're willing to invest in
skills and invest your time and do the
repetitions and gain leverage to
increase your output and are willing to
move things from monthly to weekly
weekly to daily daily to hourly and
continue to pull forward your reality on
a faster and faster Pace then I think
you'll love this video about how to get
ahead of the 99% of people